[SPEAKER_05]: is one of the most in terms of its relevance.
[SPEAKER_05]: The topic for the session is what are the impacts of the Middle East crisis on African economies as we explore issues related to global necessity and financial agency and Africa's response.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think taking a look at some of the issues that are risen in African economies,
[SPEAKER_05]: We know that the crisis in the Middle East has disrupted global trade.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's affected supply chains and also increased market volatility.
[SPEAKER_05]: By mid-2023, overall consumer prices registered historic lows.
[SPEAKER_05]: In January 2006,
[SPEAKER_05]: The Suez Canal recorded just 150 container ships in transit, a 17% year-over-year drop from an already depressed January 2025 baseline.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is the deepest January for the short ones in almost January.
[SPEAKER_05]: At the same time, roughly 70% of the cargo ships that historically used to be in the Suez are now going through
[SPEAKER_05]: going around the Cape of New Hope, South Africa.
[SPEAKER_05]: This has tripled the amount of oceanic traffic along this African coast, and added not only 2,500 additional musical miles to the journey, but almost two weeks in traffic.
[SPEAKER_05]: Finally, this year, UNDP has personalized with the African Government Bank, the Economic Commission for Africa, and the African Union Commission, and it did a report
[SPEAKER_05]: on not just what some of the key impacts are, but what African countries can do.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let me just summarize two key findings of that report.
[SPEAKER_05]: The first is something we call compounding vulnerabilities.
[SPEAKER_05]: We noticed that a complex and non-operational vacuum, it functions as a multiplier in terms of existing structural damage, such as post-pandemic damage, scare, scarring,
[SPEAKER_05]: and climate shocks.
[SPEAKER_05]: It is worth noting that the shocks from the COVID crisis are affecting Africa in terms of time, where most of them are still struggling to recover from the twin effects of COVID and the onset of the Ukraine war.
[SPEAKER_05]: Prior to the crisis, we had estimated that recovery in Africa should happen around 2028.
[SPEAKER_05]: So this further affects Africa's
[SPEAKER_05]: capacity to address the impacts effectively.
[SPEAKER_05]: Second broad conclusion that we drew was that we see divergent structural parts.
[SPEAKER_05]: The macro impact is deeply replicated.
[SPEAKER_05]: On the one hand, we have the energy importance, which is the temporary windfall, and in its food and energy importance, we face immediate fiscal compression.
[SPEAKER_05]: In addition,
[SPEAKER_05]: Countries that try to mitigate the socio-economic effects of the conflict primarily by using subsidies and tax breaks exerted against the fiscal stress of the economy.
[SPEAKER_05]: We highlighted five channels.
[SPEAKER_05]: Maritime and trade disruption channel, energy and fertilizer volatility channel, monetary exchange rates and commission channel, financial market and investment
[SPEAKER_05]: We concluded that this problem demands a comprehensive and coordinated solution.
[SPEAKER_05]: And that is exactly what we are here to discuss during this session.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's an honor to introduce the panel.
[SPEAKER_05]: We don't have .
[SPEAKER_05]: So we have Dr. Marcella Ndoguta.
[SPEAKER_05]: Lead Economist of the African Development Bank Group, are you here?
[SPEAKER_05]: Dr. Arif Suleiman from the Islamic Development Bank.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mr. MacDonald Gouanou from the ECOWAS Bank for Investment and Development.
[SPEAKER_05]: Dr. Hassan Hossam.
[SPEAKER_05]: Chairman of the National Economic Council and Chief Economic Advisor to the President of the Republic of Somalia, and Dr. Bebo Amri Salam, Lead Advisor, African Government Prime Group.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I'm wondering if Dr. Andrew Dallin from the World Bank is online.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am here, I am here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_05]: from being patient and for during the rest of the conversation.
[SPEAKER_05]: So let's start with you, and with all of us.
[SPEAKER_05]: With 29 African currencies depreciating since the onset of the conflict, the cost of servicing gets skyrocketing, and other economic consequences, what immediate interventions is the World Bank prepared to deploy
[SPEAKER_05]: and how should the global financial architecture be reformed to offer Africa better contingency financing during exogenous shocks?
[SPEAKER_05]: Quite a bit of a mouthful, but I believe we do have a question.
[SPEAKER_05]: And so, Andrew, you have five minutes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Excellent.
[SPEAKER_00]: So let me start by saying what we are trying to do with our
[SPEAKER_00]: counterparts, African government counterparts.
[SPEAKER_00]: The first is that when we actually, in the process of typical relationships, we have built in a lot of these countries contingency support.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we have projects governments basically can call upon immediately
[SPEAKER_00]: to replenish supply chain disruptions.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they have what we call the contingency and emergency response activities.
[SPEAKER_00]: We call them SIRS.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have rapid response operations that we can deploy when governments need.
[SPEAKER_00]: So even within the existing portfolio,
[SPEAKER_00]: the World Bank has basically agreed with the government for provisions in which they can call upon these financing instruments when they need them for these kinds of emergencies.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's first.
[SPEAKER_00]: Second thing is we can immediately work with the governments to actually process first quick disbursing operations to meet any kinds of emergencies.
[SPEAKER_00]: The third is if it is needed, we can modernize longer-term project developments.
[SPEAKER_00]: that could be, you know, development policy operations or it could be just investment projects.
[SPEAKER_00]: So those are some of the instruments that we provide.
[SPEAKER_00]: We also provide government support in terms of, you know, procurement support in the event that in fact they want to diversify places where they can obtain some of these supplies
[SPEAKER_00]: of commodities like oil, gas, or any type of chemicals like fertilizer that have been disrupted, you can help them find alternative suppliers.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's another one.
[SPEAKER_00]: The third way in which we can help these countries is, of course, with a structured technical policy dialogue around
[SPEAKER_00]: measures that they can put in place to be able to respond to this shock box.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this could be how you use regulatory mechanisms to try and make markets work better, regulatory mechanisms that make certain investors enter the market that were completely locked out.
[SPEAKER_00]: But we also discussed issues around monetary policy and how to use those to respond, how to monitor inflation, and so on and so on.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, that saying, I think the question you asked about how can the international financial institutions be designed to respond better, the most obvious one is, of course, to make two things much more
[SPEAKER_00]: common and available.
[SPEAKER_00]: One is how to make concessional financing much more, you know, a much larger pool of financial, you know, concessional financing.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is increasingly becoming difficult, of course, but in fact, there is a case for it, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because multilateral government banks like, you know, the World Bank, African Parliament Bank, IMF, have been designed precisely for these kinds of
[SPEAKER_00]: events or these kinds of issues, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And the last resort settlement, financial settlements for countries so that they can come to these places and be able to show up their finances to weather the storm of shocks.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's important.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's something to advocate for.
[SPEAKER_00]: The other one is this idea of making sure that there is an international mechanism that is going to actually have
[SPEAKER_00]: are better prospects for sovereign wealth and sovereign debt resolution.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right now we don't have that.
[SPEAKER_00]: We don't really have, we have G20 framework and everyone, you know, have complained about G20 framework, including we in the World Bank have basically made a case for making it faster, making it more fair, making sure that the, that the governments that come to the,
[SPEAKER_00]: to this common framework are not penalized in the markets and they continue to have access.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact, there are periods in which during the period of negotiations, maybe the debt services are postponed and so on and so on.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we need multiple suggestions and we are members of the round table.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think the common framework has been relatively slow
[SPEAKER_00]: that too many actors whose incentives are not aligned, and so that's part of the reason, but it could still be led towards debt.
[SPEAKER_00]: But what that means is maybe getting a mechanism, an internationally acceptable debt resolution mechanism for sovereign debt, like the same way we have it for private debt or corporate debt at the moment.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we don't have that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But that should be the feature that we should aspire to.
[SPEAKER_00]: So let me stop here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much, Andrew.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think excellent points on the new facilities that the bank is making available to affected countries.
[SPEAKER_05]: But let me just really ask a question on this DEX facility that will either improve or replace.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm not sure what your persuasion is on this.
[SPEAKER_05]: the common framework.
[SPEAKER_05]: If you had to advise and redesign the approach, what would you recommend and where would you be housed?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think, okay, so my recommendation of course would be something that builds on the common framework.
[SPEAKER_00]: make it more fair, quicker, and maybe have some kind of pre-agreed parameters between both the creditors and the debtors.
[SPEAKER_00]: So these are all going to be contingent contracts, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So if this happens, this is the process.
[SPEAKER_00]: If this happens, this is the process.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, you can't write complete contingent contracts because of uncertainty and a lot of different contexts that arise.
[SPEAKER_00]: The world is a very dynamic process, so you learn, you revise this stuff, but you can see the contours of that, which is you agree on a set of, you know, extended parameters based on the, you know, the outcomes, future outcomes of specific types of debt sovereign crisis possibilities.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then you do this very quickly, you resolve this very quickly, so that, you know, the countries can get back
[SPEAKER_00]: on a trajectory of debt relief and therefore back to growing.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the creditors also get their dual relief.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that would be the mechanism.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, where would you house it?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think the most natural place to house it is someplace, some institution that has developed credibility or recognized internationally as a place for arbitrating these kinds
[SPEAKER_00]: these kinds of resolutions, these kinds of disputes, or these kinds of mechanisms, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't name any one institution right away, but that is something for the international financial community to agree on, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: They can decide where to pass that on the basis of what kinds of institutions have what capacity.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much, Andrew, for that.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll turn to Dr. Nasir Rahim Taha from the African Development Bank.
[SPEAKER_05]: We know that the current position of the board, as I mentioned earlier, is to fast-track implementation of counter-cyclical crisis response measures.
[SPEAKER_05]: As Africa's premier financial institution, how is the AFP leading in these areas, and to what extent is its expansion into the cities of mobilization
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you have rightly mentioned, the VAT is really the Africa's premier financing institution.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as per this mandate, our mission of contributing to the sustainable economic development and social progress through its RFCs, meaning regional new VAT companies, which are the 54 African companies,
[SPEAKER_02]: Both individually and collectively, the Bank is playing a leading role on crisis response program to its RMCs for regard to the Middle East crisis.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is consistent with the strong commitment the Bank revealed in the recent past in helping RMCs to cope with multiple global shocks
[SPEAKER_02]: namely the outbreak of the Russia-Ukraine conflict, the lasting effects of the COVID crisis, and also the impact of the climate crisis.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you know, knowledge informs our population and also our policy.
[SPEAKER_02]: In this respect, the Bank first focused on getting a detailed understanding
[SPEAKER_02]: of the impact of the current crisis by coordinating with UNDP and UNECA the assessment of how this crisis affects African economies.
[SPEAKER_02]: The bank also produced concrete notes on the safety for the 54 African countries.
[SPEAKER_02]: The findings of these knowledge weights are used to guide IRC's
[SPEAKER_02]: in the preparation of their responses to the impact of the Middle East crisis.
[SPEAKER_02]: Moreover, the Bank is planning to support financially its IMCs through a global energy and vitalizer crisis response facility, which is under preparation and which is informed by the findings of the joint policy prepared for use by the Bank
[SPEAKER_02]: UNDP and UNETA.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, regarding the civil aspect, the bank supports also the RLCs in the, to strengthen the domestic resource mobilization.
[SPEAKER_02]: But this is not a counter-psychical operation.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's part of the bank's standard intervention through institutional support project and also project support.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is in line also with about four cardinal points, in particular the cardinal point number one, which is related to mobilizing the sources .
[SPEAKER_02]: So .
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much, Dr. .
[SPEAKER_05]: And let's see with financial institutions, let's move to Dr. .
[SPEAKER_05]: Given the
[SPEAKER_05]: Even if I actually need a position in bridging the Middle East, Africa, and the States, how are we leveraging trade financing facilities to secure critical energy and agricultural supplies and to advocate for things that have been affected by what's going on, particularly around the Red Sea on the surface?
[SPEAKER_04]: Sir, thank you for the tune.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you stop by saying some finance is not a source of wealth, that would be incident from the general African country, but you'll be following from the text of the process.
[SPEAKER_04]: What it does do is very, very important for in terms of the stabilising of the payment and access to trade plans, supporting essential imports, and strengthening economic resilience through periods of heightened uncertainty.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, from the Social Development Bank perspective, our critical advantage lies in our ability to connect our African member countries with trade, financial, and investment capabilities of countries in the Middle East and the world as well as South.
[SPEAKER_04]: We've repeatedly tapped into our approach to enable the group to mobilize support for vulnerable member countries, specifically during times of crisis.
[SPEAKER_04]: But the environment has become a lot more difficult.
[SPEAKER_04]: crops are no longer isolated, they persist in overlapping and increasing.
[SPEAKER_04]: We are taking both vulnerable countries and traditional sources of liquidity, investment, and solidarity.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we look at our 27 African-American countries, 22 of these are in stage of heightened fragility, which means we live in a nightmare.
[SPEAKER_04]: 22 are also commodity-model economies, and 10 of these economies
[SPEAKER_04]: either cannot even get the special archives of the .
[SPEAKER_04]: They're not independent of each other.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight of these countries have .
[SPEAKER_04]: The hope of this crisis, it seems like we've been here before.
[SPEAKER_04]: We've had this for such a long time.
[SPEAKER_04]: It feels like we're moving down .
[SPEAKER_04]: We've been in this case multiple times.
[SPEAKER_04]: The most recent one, in 2022,
[SPEAKER_04]: We had the same energy and with about five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Then we were able to mobilize resources from the other coordination group and we came up with a food security response program.
[SPEAKER_04]: At that point, it took over 10 and a half million dollars.
[SPEAKER_04]: This time around, the crisis lifted.
[SPEAKER_04]: These general companies that were supporting us and could co-finance some of those dollars are being affected by the very
[SPEAKER_04]: crisis that we're facing now.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, financing has become a lot tighter.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, some finance is there, it's part of the toolkit, it is not the only solution, and actually, you know, it's an alternative to conventional finance, it is part of the overall financing toolkit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, in terms of what the ISP is doing directly upon the trade finance system, it responds to this.
[SPEAKER_04]: At our recent annual meetings, two weeks back,
[SPEAKER_04]: We signed a pay finance corporation, signed a federal agreement before our exit in 2010, and that's a total of $2.75 billion worth of pay financing that will be made available to these countries from the period 2026 to 2029.
[SPEAKER_04]: But we were also signed by one of the four countries, which we signed a $715 million federal agreement.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, despite this challenging environment, we continue to scale up our financing, for example, the approval and the statements.
[SPEAKER_04]: From 2015 to now, we've introduced approvals from just over $6.8 billion to a current level of $10.5 billion, or $16 billion.
[SPEAKER_04]: And from the defense's perspective, also up now to $11 billion.
[SPEAKER_04]: So Islamic finance is part of the overall financing toolkit.
[SPEAKER_04]: helps us move quickly.
[SPEAKER_04]: And as I explained yesterday, I'll repeat that point again today, is that the Islamic trade finance is an up-and-coming finance.
[SPEAKER_04]: So all that could happen, the simple trade finance standard, if a country wants to support or any agriculture or anything in terms of agriculture, we would then buy that on their behalf.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so we would buy the commodity and sell it at the market.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's all it is.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_05]: You correctly pointed out that it seems like ground concrete.
[SPEAKER_05]: It seems like we've been there before.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I think the case could be made.
[SPEAKER_05]: So looking forward, what should you do differently?
[SPEAKER_05]: What should our institutions do differently?
[SPEAKER_05]: What should they do to differentiate in this context of recurring and more frequently recurring crises?
[SPEAKER_04]: I think one of those is the people's responses.
[SPEAKER_04]: When I look at the predictions in 2008, the responses on the different levels were pretty similar.
[SPEAKER_04]: So each one came up with a different problem.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's possible that they've never experienced going forward.
[SPEAKER_04]: we need to start working with data services and collaborating more, not, you know, you all say you want to coordinate, you need to coordinate, but no one wants to coordinate.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think that's a challenge that we need to overcome from the multi-lateral perspective.
[SPEAKER_04]: We've got to work on that.
[SPEAKER_04]: We've got to just do a lot more than happen, but not enough is not good enough.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_05]: As we move to Mr. Donner's call-out,
[SPEAKER_05]: and from the ECOWAS Bank for Investments and Developments.
[SPEAKER_05]: How is your institution navigating this investment strategy to keep critical institutional infrastructure and development projects viable despite soaring inflation in the Pacific Ocean?
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let me first of all thank you to the 10 panelists.
[SPEAKER_04]: Everyone makes a difference.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because we argue
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: In the last few years, we have been in normal strife in terms of financial infrastructure within the Soviet Union.
[SPEAKER_04]: Today, we are actually engaged in Nigeria,
[SPEAKER_04]: We have a lot of stuff.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nigeria, we have .
[SPEAKER_04]: So people .
[SPEAKER_04]: One of the key challenges we also have
[SPEAKER_04]: .
.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's why our .
[SPEAKER_04]: It means that you want to go there, you want to go there, you have to be not for the leverage.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, you know, our first strategy is just, you know, it's called growth.
[SPEAKER_04]: Growth, resilience, optimization.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, we are targeting a lot of things.
[SPEAKER_04]: We are targeting a lot of things.
We are targeting a lot of things.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: We found that, we did an assessment studying food security, we found that 29% of our population are food insecure, 40% are only marginally food secure, and 68% depend on markets for their foods, yet 10%
[SPEAKER_01]: that they need without assistance.
[SPEAKER_01]: These findings are specific to Somalia, but they are also reflective of other countries in the same context.
[SPEAKER_01]: These figures reveal a broader economic reality in countries in similar contexts.
[SPEAKER_01]: external shocks are transmitted through food systems into the wider economy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, higher import costs mean higher inflation, weaker household demand, lower trade rate and higher fiscal space, and also reduce the space for policy flexibility.
[SPEAKER_01]: So food insecurity is an issue,
[SPEAKER_01]: but it is actually a manifestation of a wider underlying economic resilience.
[SPEAKER_01]: This would demand a different policy response.
[SPEAKER_01]: This has been talked about all today.
[SPEAKER_01]: First, I think we needed to mobilize more domestic capital.
[SPEAKER_01]: We cannot build resilience while
[SPEAKER_01]: primarily relying on external financing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Second, I think our development in finance must shift from ex-post solutions and emerging response into ex-ante investment.
[SPEAKER_01]: Third, I think we must strengthen the value chains
[SPEAKER_01]: increase productive capacity and deep and regional integration to reduce strategic dependence on external supply chains.
[SPEAKER_01]: And finally, we should not measure our success by how we respond to crisis.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we should measure our success by how we make our economies less vulnerable
[SPEAKER_01]: to the next crisis.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think from Somalia, we are progressing well, and all of these solutions are integrated within our Vision 2060 and the International Terms Formation 1.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we don't need more emergency funding.
[SPEAKER_01]: We would rather need fewer emergencies.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think last week I had Dr. Vero from GFPB.
[SPEAKER_05]: She can share her thoughts with us and also maybe teach you a little bit more about what you are assessing
[SPEAKER_03]: various today's discussion that took place today.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, starting from the topic we're discussing now, we are going to start, the situation is almost up in the presence.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, we are going to go on later, but what do we observe?
[SPEAKER_03]: How it affects the African economies?
[SPEAKER_03]: And finally, something I'd like to say about that.
[SPEAKER_03]: From your point of view,
[SPEAKER_03]: We see different transmission challenges, energy, fertilizers, and other issues.
[SPEAKER_03]: But that's also a challenge for the financial condition.
[SPEAKER_03]: How it affects the various economies.
[SPEAKER_03]: For the key of the report, 54 countries, 82 sites, are leveled for imports.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we see this to affect the African GDP by 2% in fact.
[SPEAKER_03]: But also the magnitude,
[SPEAKER_03]: This is a huge, huge challenge.
[SPEAKER_03]: But of course, we have to look at the other components.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fertilizers.
[SPEAKER_03]: 80%, 86% increase in the cost of the fertilizers.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hence, the HDB response to that, and our leading colleague here, Marcelo, was quite clear about how the HDB has been presumed to do it.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need to see also how we respond collectively on the system.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think some of the challenges we see is .
[SPEAKER_03]: So we need to see how we come with a more synergistic approach, looking at our respective comparative within the respective block or regions of this, looking at us as well as the various systems.
[SPEAKER_03]: that is coming as opposed to in the ADF replenishments from the .
[SPEAKER_03]: So we need to see how this ecosystem can work for better, especially looking at two components.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, previsibility and then strategic response.
[SPEAKER_03]: In between, I would say, bringing the capacity at the national level.
[SPEAKER_03]: Capacity, institutional capacity, on one hand.
[SPEAKER_03]: Second, capacity on project design, preparation, implementation.
[SPEAKER_03]: But also capacity in terms of progress mobilization, in particular on the domestic side.
[SPEAKER_03]: Looking at, talking to colleagues here, we know that tax-gidding pollution in some of the countries is only one single issue.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why?
[SPEAKER_03]: among the fastest.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we need also to see how we address these parts.
[SPEAKER_03]: So all in all, I would say for me the critical point of the common denominator here would be how we work collectively in a synergistic way as a system.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is the approach I will see and look at my platform.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much for those thoughts.
[SPEAKER_05]: I will now have time for
[SPEAKER_05]: Two or three short questions and comments.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you have any questions and comments?
[SPEAKER_05]: Show of hands.
[SPEAKER_05]: One here, any others?
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, we'll have one question and we'll go back to the panel.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you very much for the opportunity.
[SPEAKER_05]: I just want to take the opportunity
[SPEAKER_05]: to clarify an earlier comment, necessarily by Mr. MacDonald.
[SPEAKER_05]: And regarding Africa's debt, so maybe it would be a bit off tangent, but I'll just keep it the same.
[SPEAKER_05]: When Professor Sachs made his comment, I wanted to give the chief in that, whereas it looks like Africa's debt is a bit unmanageable, but I think that
[SPEAKER_05]: we really need to step up because what the world is telling us is that we're incapable of development and we're incapable of managing money.
[SPEAKER_05]: Africa's debt is 1.8% of global, that's 1.8% of global debt.
[SPEAKER_05]: Australia's debt alone is almost the whole of Africa's debt.
[SPEAKER_05]: And so maybe if the world will have the highest returns on their investments here in Manila,
[SPEAKER_05]: in Africa, I'm asking why not?
[SPEAKER_05]: Africa's debt is about 38% debt to GDP in Africa.
[SPEAKER_05]: Europe is 80%.
[SPEAKER_05]: USA alone is 122%.
[SPEAKER_05]: China is 80% officially, 300% unofficially.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now, so I think we need to have a different, we can't give up on ourselves.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's why I wanted to tell Mr. McDonald that we can't give up on ourselves.
[SPEAKER_05]: We haven't even started.
[SPEAKER_05]: I wrote another school in some of our local journals in Nigeria, things like that.
[SPEAKER_05]: The world has probably not started to invest in Africa, and that's the truth.
[SPEAKER_05]: However, I believe that we deserve the investment.
[SPEAKER_05]: There's so much to do in Africa, there's so much to cover, and so I wanted to drop that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Perhaps, last thing to say, that perhaps we can find a way of ensuring that borrowings in Africa should be directed solely at value-added transactions
[SPEAKER_05]: development infrastructure and things that have some cash flow inside them that can actually run at least part of those needs.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_05]: Great points.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think that's a conversation that is going to take up bilaterally.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let me then want to do, because we are pressed for time,
[SPEAKER_05]: and I'm getting those from the few callers already, but this comes down the pattern, starting with you at the bottom.
[SPEAKER_05]: One solution that you need us to, and if somebody else has sent you a solution, think about that a little bit.
[SPEAKER_05]: So you have to do that first.
[SPEAKER_05]: One solution in like one minute or less that you think you need us to try to focus on
[SPEAKER_05]: to the countries to respond to the current shock and .
[SPEAKER_03]: One of the solutions we are contemplating is guaranteed .
[SPEAKER_03]: financing architecture for development in Africa.
[SPEAKER_03]: So part of the solution, the African Development Bank increased by five times its equity participation to RCD.
[SPEAKER_03]: RCD is African Trade Investment Development Institution based in Nairobi.
[SPEAKER_03]: So the aim is to leverage from $830 million equity to $2 billion equity.
[SPEAKER_03]: And therefore, having the capacity to leverage the guarantees up to $20 billion.
[SPEAKER_03]: And there is a call from the FDA to bring us other African institutions to be part of this solution.
[SPEAKER_03]: And therefore, this will help against the issue of debt, especially part of the debt structure, government debt structure, is foreign currency.
[SPEAKER_03]: Therefore, we'll be able to finance it as a long-term investment, but that's when you look at us.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_05]: I have over one minute.
[SPEAKER_05]: But what about your colleagues?
[SPEAKER_01]: I would say it would be coordination across the continent, trying to forge common response when crises occur.
[SPEAKER_01]: But even before that, have the resilience in creating our continental and individual country
[SPEAKER_02]: from an employee to sustain the effort to accelerate the structural transformation of our economies to reduce their vulnerability.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because once the economy is very resilient in terms of creating decent jobs, in terms of creating wealth and so on, the shop will be there in time.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the government is on the way.
Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_04]: The question is about
[SPEAKER_04]: opportunity to see that we can build, I would like to go back to last week's point, we can build resilience and build, to see that sharks cannot be quarreling all of the time when we are at the other end.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, just quickly, we'll talk about that.
[SPEAKER_04]: You know, I come from a country of England, that is not a bad thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can't compare Australia
[SPEAKER_04]: in the United States.
[SPEAKER_04]: The problem they're having in Africa is debt repayment.
They think that's income.
They think that's a pay.
It's not.
[SPEAKER_05]: All of the other things they're having.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was in Senegal.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was in Côte d'Ivoire very soon.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was talking to a friend of our country.
[SPEAKER_04]: .
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_05]: Andrew, do you have a last word?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I would say something that is...
[SPEAKER_00]: I would say something that is in the power...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so let me... Can you hear me?
[SPEAKER_05]: We can hear you now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, my intervention is basically two in one, which is efficient spending of what you already are collecting and changing the composition of that spending so that it is allocated between protecting basic services and growth potential.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is something that is in the control of every African country, and they can do it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much for that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let me just highlight five things from this session.
[SPEAKER_05]: The first is that the Middle East is a compounding vulnerability for African countries.
[SPEAKER_05]: Second, international organizations and international institutions are responding.
[SPEAKER_05]: but they need to move more and faster.
[SPEAKER_05]: Third, African countries are also responding, but we need fiscal responsibility, consistency, and cooperation.
[SPEAKER_05]: And four, regional institutions matter.
[SPEAKER_05]: They can handle change.
[SPEAKER_05]: And five, Africa needs to be prepared for a new normal where shops are more frequent and possibly even deeper than in the past.
[SPEAKER_05]: So thank you all for participating, and thank the IxOS panel.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you, Andrew, for joining us online.
[SPEAKER_05]: Andrew, keep your video up for the photograph.
[SPEAKER_05]: So we'll see you in the background.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK. We'll have a family photograph.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thanks.